As we touched on earlier in this class,
rendering pages quickly is super important.
Let's think about this for a moment.
Because if you can request data asynchronously you open up
a new range of ways for making fast page loads.
Let's think about this Facebook for food app over here.
Where I've got my favorite cereal, favorite pasta, favorite meal, and
how I like my eggs.
It's displaying custom content based on me being the user.
Take a look at some possible steps for rendering this app.
In what order could we run these steps to get the first pixels on
the screen over here as fast as possible?
Just to be clear, generic refers to HTML that would be the same for all users.
That would be the HTML for
let's say favorite cereal, favorite pasta, it can also even be CSS for,
you know, how to style this image and how to style all this text.
Unique HTML refers to things like the strings for
my name, the strings for all my favorite foods.
Because this is unique to me specifically.